we've come to the Kalahari Desert in
Africa to witness one of my nature z'
classic confrontations in this corner of
the desert feeding on succulent bulbs
insects and small vertebrates that
sociable critter the meerkat in this
corner of the desert feeding on rodents
birds other snakes and of course
meerkats
with a nasty deadly venomous bite that
can easily kill humans the puff adder
you think the meerkats would vamoose out
of there with a threat like this and but
knew they bunched tightly together they
actually advance on the puff adder puff
adder versus meerkat meerkats versus
puff adder eyeball-to-eyeball who's
gonna blink first the meerkats smartly
wave their tails high in the air to
focus the snakes attention there and to
keep it from striking at their heads the
fuzzy adorable meerkats
actually have the puff adder retreating
the meerkat puffs look on as the adults
take care of business
I think we've got a winner
it's the meerkats in a unanimous
decision as the puff adder skedaddled
and the meerkats marinate in the glory
of victory